TALK ABOUT BEING TRIGGERED.
IS ANYBODY BUYING THIS POLITICAL
CIRCUS?
JOINING US NOW WITH MORE IS FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR SARA CARTER AND
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR SARA CARTER ANDTHE AUTHOR OF "WITCH HUNT," GREG
THE AUTHOR OF "WITCH HUNT," GREG
JARRETT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING ME
TONIGHT.
I KNOW WE’RE GOING TO GET DOWN
TO THE HEART OF WHAT ALL OF THIS
IS.
WHAT WE JUST LISTENED TO IS
AWFUL.
GREG, LET ME START WITH YOU.
WE SEE A NUMBER OF HEADLINES
HERE.
AFTER ALL OF THIS STUFF WITH THE
IMPEACHMENT ABOUT HOW IT WAS
URGENT AND KEPT THE REPUBLICANS
FROM BEING ABLE TO DO CERTAIN
THINGS, TIME WAS SHORT BECAUSE
WE HAD THIS BAD HORRIBLE MAN IN
THE WHITE HOUSE THAT HAD TO BE
STOPPED.
SUDDENLY NOW IT’S LIKE, OH,
WE’VE GOT ALL OF THE TIME IN THE
WORLD.
MEDIA IS ARGUING ABOUT HOW THIS
IS A GENIUS STRATEGY.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON IT?
>> NOBODY TAKES RICHARD PAINTER
SERIOUSLY, WHICH IS WHY HE’S ON
MSNBC AND CNN.
THIS IS THE GUY WHO SUED TRUMP
THREE DAYS AFTER HE TOOK OFFICE.
SO, HE’S UTTERLY IRRELEVANT AND
A JOKE.
BUT AS TO YOUR QUESTION, YOU
KNOW, THE FRAMERS NEVER
ENVISIONED A STUNT PULLED BY A
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE LIKE NANCY
PELOSI HOLDING ON TO ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT.
TWO DECADES AGO WAS SENT OVER
IMMEDIATELY, WITHIN MINUTES,
THERE WAS A VOTE TO CONVEY AND
TRANSMIT IT.
THE CONSTITUTION IS ACTUALLY
SILENT ABOUT THAT.
IT DOESN’T SAY THAT THE SENATE
HAS TO WAIT UNTIL IT’S
TRANSMITTED.
IT’S SIMPLY A SENATE RULE.
MITCH McCONNELL SHOULDN’T BE
SUBJECTING HIMSELF TO THE
EXTORTION OF NANCY PELOSI.
HE CAN BEGINNING IN JANUARY
SIMPLY ALTER THE RULE OR
ELIMINATE IT ENTIRELY AND SET A
DATE FOR AN IMPEACHMENT TRIAL.
PELOSI WANTS TO DEPRIVE TRUMP OF
SORT OF A SIXTH AMENDMENT RIGHT,
SORT OF A SIXTH AMENDMENT RIGHT,YES, IT’S NOT A CRIMINAL TRIAL,
YES, IT’S NOT A CRIMINAL TRIAL,
BUT THE PRINCIPLE APPLIES,
CONFRONTING YOUR ACCUSER.
HE ENTITLED TO A TRIAL, AN
ACQUITTAL, IF THAT’S WHAT THE
SUPER MAJORITY DECIDES -- OR THE
MAJORITY WOULD DECIDE.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A SUPER
MAJORITY TO REMOVE HIM.
>> WELL THIS, OF COURSE, SARAH,
WE’VE SEEP THIS BEFORE.
IT’S IN THEIR NATURE TO DENY DUE
PROCESS TO SOMEONE THEY ACCUSED.
PROCESS TO SOMEONE THEY ACCUSED.YOU THINK OF JUSTICE KAVANAUGH,
YOU THINK OF JUSTICE KAVANAUGH,
MONTHS, WEEKS OF TRYING TO
DESTROY THAT MAN’S CHARACTER.
AND THEN JUST THROWING HIM OUT,
RIGHT?
THAT WAS DONE.
THEY’VE ACCOMPLISHED THAT.
IT LOOKS LIKE THEY WANT TO
ACCOMPLISH THE SAME THING HERE.
IS THAT YOUR SENSE?
SOME PEOPLE THINK THAT PELOSI IS
SERIOUS AND SHE REALLY WANTS
FAIRNESS IN THE SENATE WHEN SHE
DIDN’T, OF COURSE, AFFORD THAT
TO THE PRESIDENT.
WHAT’S YOUR TAKE ON THE REAL
AGENDA AND WHAT THE IMPACT WILL
BE ULTIMATELY ON THE DEMOCRATS.
>> IN MY OPINION, TAMMY, THE
REAL AGENDA IS THAT NANCY PELOSI
NEVER WANTED TO DO THIS TO BEGIN
WITH.
SHE KNOWS IT’S POLITICAL
SUICIDE.
AND THE ONLY THING SHE CAN DO IS
ACTUALLY HOLD ON TO THESE
PAPERS, TO NOT MOVE THE
IMPEACHMENT FORWARD IN THE
SENATE.
SHE’S STRUGGLING.
I MEAN, SHE WAS BASICALLY TAKEN
HOSTAGE BY RADICALS IN HER OWN
PARTY.
SHE TRIED TO TALK THEM OUT OF IT
IN THE BEGINNING.
THEN SHE BELIEVED ADAM SCHIFF
AND BELIEVED THAT HE HAD
PROMISED HER THEY WERE GOING TO
HAVE ALL OF THIS EVIDENCE IN THE
HOUSE HEARINGS, THAT THEY WERE
GOING TO PROVE THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS IMPEACHABLE, AND
THEY WERE GOING TO HAVE ALL OF
THIS EVIDENCE AND THEY HAD NO
EVIDENCE.
THEY HAD NOTHING AT ALL.
SO, WHAT HAPPENED WAS, ALL OF A
SUDDEN, WE HAVE A VERY PARTISAN
STRAIGHT DOWN THE MIDDLE
IMPEACHMENT IN THE HOUSE.
NANCY PELOSI KNOWS IF SHE TAKES
IT TO THE SENATE, IT’S NOT GOING
TO BE GOOD FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
THE ONLY THING SHE CAN DO RIGHT
NOW IS HOLD ON TO THOSE ARTICLES
OF IMPEACHMENT.
AND BY THE WAY, ANOTHER POINT
HERE, A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE TRYING
TO MAKE OUT ON THE DEMOCRAT
SIDE, AND EVEN JENNIFER RUBEN
WITH "THE WASHINGTON POST" LIKE
SHE’S SOME KIND OF GENIUS FOR
DOING THIS.
THIS WAS HER ONLY OPTION.
IT’S NOT LIKE SHE THOUGHT ABOUT
THIS BEFORE SHE WENT INTO IT.
SHE JUST HAS NO OTHER WAY OUT OF
IT.
AND SHE’S GOING TO PAY HER
CARDS.
>> IN FACT, PERHAPS THIS WAS THE
PLAN FROM THE START ULTIMATELY.
BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN A SCHEME AND
THEY REALLY HAVE NOT -- THEY
HAVEN’T CARED ABOUT THE IMPACT
ON THE COUNTRY.
BUT, GREG, THERE’S A PRESUMPTION
IT SEEMS FROM THE DEMOCRATS THAT
IT SEEMS FROM THE DEMOCRATS THATTHE REPUBLICANS WILL ALLOW THIS
THE REPUBLICANS WILL ALLOW THIS
TO CONTINUE.
MAYBE SHEA DO -- THEY DO THINK
THE PRESIDENT’S NUMBERS HAVE
GONE UP.
THEY’VE SEEN IMPEACHMENT GO UP
AS WELL.
BUT ISN’T IT PROPER BECAUSE IF
THE CONSTITUTION THAT SAYS THEY
THEY DON’T -- THERE’S NOTHING IN
THE CONSTITUTION THAT SAYS THEY HAVE TO DO THIS AS YOU’VE NOTED.
HAVE TO DO THIS AS YOU’VE NOTED.
AND THEY CAN CHANGE THE RULE
EASILY.
SHOULD WE EXPECT THEM THE DO
THAT, WOULD IT BE BETTER FOR
THEM TO DO THAT?
OR WOULD THIS CHARADE CONTINUE
TO BE EXPOSED BY LETTING IT SIT?
>> WELL, THE CHOICE IS TWOFOLD.
MITCH McCONNELL CAN SAY IF
YOU’RE NOT GOING TO SEND HIM
OVER, I DON’T CARE.
WE’RE NOT GOING TO DEAL WITH IT.
NANCY PELOSI COULD THEN USE IT
AS A CODGEL TO HIT TRUMP OVER
THE HEAD AT EVERY TURN.
>> ADD THINGS TO IT.
>> SIMPLY CHANGE THE RULE, HOLD
A TRIAL, DO IT ON YOUR OWN
TERMS.
YOU KNOW?
THE CONSTITUTION DOESN’T SAY THE
SOLE POWER TO TRIAL IMPEACHMENT
WITH THE CONSENT AND ADVICE OF
NANCY PELOSI.
IT DID YOU WANT
IT -- IT DOESN’T SAY THAT.
>> THAT’S THE BIG DEAL.
SARAH, IN FACT, ALL OF THIS IS
POLITICS.
WE KNOW THIS.
AND THE REPUBLICANS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT’S HAPPENING
HERE.
BUT WE AS THE CITIZENS WITH
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW THE
CONSTITUTION IS BEING SHREDDED
AT THIS POINT AND MADE A MOCKERY
OF.
IF THE REPUBLICANS WENT AHEAD
AND THEY KNOW WHAT THE ARTICLES
OF IMPEACHMENT ARE, THEY’VE SEEN
WHAT THE DYNAMIC IS, DO YOU
THINK THAT WOULD BE IN THE LONG
RUN, PRESIDENT TRUMP, OF COURSE,
RUN, PRESIDENT TRUMP, OF COURSE,WOULD BE EXONERATED, DO UH  YOU
WOULD BE EXONERATED, DO UH  YOU
THINK THAT’S THE BEST WAY GO?
OR AGAIN THE ARGUMENT THAT
AMERICANS SHOULD SEE THE
DEMOCRATS FOR WHAT THEY ARE.
>> LOOK, IN MY PERSONAL OPINION,
I THINK AMERICA HAS ALREADY SEEN
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DON’T WANT
THE DEMOCRATS FOR WHAT THEY ARE.
TO PUT UP WITH THIS.
WE’VE SEEN THE NUMBERS TURN IN
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S FAVOR.
OF COURSE AS MITCH McCONNELL
MAKES THAT DECISION, THEY MAKE
THE DECISION TO MOVE WITH A FAST
AND SPEEDY TRIAL IN THIS
IMPEACHMENT CHARADE, THAT’S
GOING TO BE THEIR PREROGATIVE
AND THEIR CHOICE.
BUT I THINK RIGHT NOW, THE
DEMOCRATS ARE SHOWING THE PUBLIC
WHO THEY ARE AND  THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO SHOW THAT.
THEY HAVE NOWHERE TO GO HERE.
THEY DON’T HAVE ANYBODY IN THEIR
PARTY COME 2020 THAT STANDS OUT
AS A FIGURE THAT CAN EVEN
CHALLENGE PRESIDENT TRUMP RIGHT
NOW AND THEY KNOW IT.
AND THEY KNOW THIS.
THIS IS DRIVING THEM MAD.
SO, THIS IS BASICALLY ALL THEY
HAVE.
THIS IS KIND OF LIKE THEIR
HURRAH.
THEIR ADVERTISEMENT.
THEIR WAY OF RAISING FUNDS.
SO I DON’T THINK IF IT GOES
EITHER WAY -- EITHER WAY THIS
GOES, IT’S NOT GOING TO BE GOOD
FOR THEM IN THE END.
SO I THINK IT’S A WIN-WIN FOR
REPUBLICANS.
>> YOU KNOW, THE REAL TRAGEDY
THAT THE BAR HAS BEEN SET SO LOW
FOR IMPEACHMENT BY NANCY PELOSI
AND ADAM SCHIFF AND JERRY
NADLER, ANY PERCEIVED OFFENSE IS
NOW IMPEACHABLE AND IT WILL
EXTEND IN PERPETUITY MORE AND
MORE IMPEACHMENTS BY DEMOCRATS
UNLESS REPUBLICAN S
UNLESS REPUBLICANS VOTE
DEMOCRATS OUT OF OFFICE.
THEY LOSE CONTROL IN THE HOUSE
AND NANCY PELOSI LOSES HER JOB.
OTHERWISE, WE’RE GOING TO SEE
MULTIPLE IMPEACHMENTS DOWN THE
ROAD.
>> IF THERE’S NOT A DRAMATIC
RESPONSE BY THE PEOPLE -- WE’RE
THE FINAL WORD -- IT WILL SEND A
THE FINAL WORD -- IT WILL SEND ASIGNAL THAT ALL OF THIS HAS BEEN
SIGNAL THAT ALL OF THIS HAS BEEN
ACCEPTABLE.
AND IT’S NOT JUST A DIFFERENCE
IN POLITICS.
WE CAN ALL DISAGREE.
THIS HAS BEEN A WANTON DISREGARD
FOR THE IMPACT NOT JUST ON OUR
SYSTEM, BUT ON THE MESSAGING IT
SENDS EVEN TO YOUNG PEOPLE IN
THE COUNTRY THAT YOU --
DESTROYING THE CHARACTER OF
SOMEONE THROUGH HOAX OR THROUGH
LIES THAT DUE PROCESS MEANS
NOTHING, THAT EQUAL JUSTICE
MEANS NOTHING, IS, OF COURSE,
IRONICALLY WHY TRUMP WAS
ELECTED.
HE’S TAKING THESE SLINGS AND
ARROWS.
AND, OF COURSE, WE’VE GOT A YEAR
COMING UP HERE WHERE WE CAN MAKE
A STATEMENT.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME, MORE DAMAGE
CAN BE DONE IF WE DON’T, IN
FACT, AND THEY’RE -- YOU KNOW
THEY’RE TOUCHING BASE AT HOME
NOW.
THEY’RE DOING POLLS.
AND THIS IS, I THINK, ALSO --
>> AMERICANS NEED TO RISE UP AND
SAY THIS IS FUNDAMENTALLY WRONG.
SAY THIS IS FUNDAMENTALLY WRONG.WE’RE NOT GOING TO ALLOW THIS TO
WE’RE NOT GOING TO ALLOW THIS TO
HAPPEN AD NAUSEAM FROM HERE ON
OUT.
AND THE ONLY WAY TO DO IT IS
WITH THEIR VOTE.
>> THAT’S IT.
>> AMERICANS WILL DO THAT AT THE
POLLS, TAMMY.
THEY WILL DO THAT AT THE POLLS.